[Music]
this morning we are taking a look at the
changing face of drug addiction in
america and how some
are trying to chart a path out of the
darkness for hundreds of thousands still
struggling
during the first year of the pandemic
more than 96 000 people died in america
from drug overdoses that is a 30 percent
increase
over the previous year and the largest
in u.s history much of that is due to
the number of illegal synthetic drugs on
the streets the number has skyrocketed
now sam quinones the man whose book
dreamland defined the opioid epidemic is
out with a new offering it's called the
least of us
and it's a wake-up call to a changing
world
my name is sam how you guys doing
[Applause]
i've written a story of how the whole
opioid epidemic and how it went from
pain pills to heroin and now i've got
writing another book
about how that then morphed into
fentanyl
methamphetamine as well
why did you feel like you had to
continue
with this subject well initially i
didn't you know initially i was worn out
i also initially thought what are you
right after heroin we met sam kinonas in
kentucky just off the banks of the ohio
river perhaps more than any other place
the epicenter of america's latest most
dangerous battle with addiction you say
there's no such thing as recreational
drug use anymore what does that mean
that means that the drugs on the street
today are more dangerous deadly
prevalent
and disguised
than ever before every time you do a
line of cocaine at a party which in the
80s 70s and 80s was like kind of you
were rude to not do it
now you don't know if that line of
cocaine has a has fentanyl in it which
could very very easily kill you it
happens all the time fentanyl is the
synthetic opioid that is 80 to 100 times
more potent than morphine it's being
added by dealers to drugs everywhere in
recent years fentanyl overdoses have
killed actor michael k williams
baseball player tyler skaggs along with
musicians prince and tom petty just to
name a few
no one is really prepared to use
fentanyl there's no such thing as a
long-term user
of fentanyl it's not just fentanyl the
production and use of all kinds of
synthetic drugs has surged in the last
five years as drugs manufactured in
illegal labs especially in mexico begin
to overtake plant-based products with
enough chemicals you can make those
drugs in staggering supplies all year
round no seasons no land you don't need
to worry about the sunlight or anything
like that kenona spent 10 years working
as a reporter in mexico then work for
the los angeles times before turning to
books
his 2015 bestseller dreamland was the
definitive account of how pharmaceutical
companies pushed painkillers like
oxycontin
heroin dealers followed in their wake
now canonist is out with the least of us
who are the least of us there are people
that are in need that we all can be like
them and given the right circumstances
or the wrong circumstances or the wrong
circumstances sure the book focuses on
potential solutions including programs
like the life learning center in
covington kentucky a building that once
helped build prisons is now helping keep
people out the bars of alcatraz were
made here yes alicia webb eddington is
the president of life learning you don't
like the term second chances for a
second chance why
transformational change transformational
employment all of us we've had more than
two chances in life
every one of us two chances we're gonna
limit people to two chances no we're
gonna transform people you also learn
some physical techniques for dealing
with negative thoughts this is not a
rehab facility it's a place where
addicts come to learn the skills to get
jobs there's even a clinic for free
tattoo removal
we met clayton carmack who spent years
abusing drugs and behind bars
why is it so important for you to get
these taken off
i can't erase all the things i've done i
can't erase the felonies they'll carry
with me for the rest of my life i'll
always have those things but being able
to walk into a room with you guys
one day and not have these tattoos that
are going to try to tell my story for me
i'm really grateful
this is an opportunity for us as a
community to make a difference webb
eddington is a former state trooper and
sheriff's deputy who for years worked
undercover narcotics she no longer
believes lock them up and throw away the
key is the answer i get some
chastisement from my fellow law
enforcement officers but also get a
great deal of support
you know alicia oh my god have you gone
soft on crime i haven't gone soft on
anything i've gone smart on it
one of the people who came here for help
is daniel woods a former golf pro who
got addicted to pills after three knee
surgeries and spent a total of 21 years
in prison it's called dodd that's up
containing dangerous drugs and one
doctor could not prescribe enough for me
it became a part to where i just seeked
out other doctors paper trail led up to
me and
i know it sounds corny but it saved my
life woods is now a life learning
employee
counseling others
if you didn't have this place where
would you be
well i can tell you i've been i've been
under bridges and been homeless
been scared to death where i would be at
today would uh
i don't even think about it
in the main hallway of life learning
there are pictures of the people who've
walked through their doors
667 this year alone if it was a drug
that could make you feel different
you were doing it
kenona's visits places like life
learning and the kenton county detention
center for insight on how to reframe our
understanding of addiction
and ways to treat it my whole life i've
been totally ignorant
about the facts of what addiction really
does to a human being do you have any
reason for hope right now
i i think so yeah i mean it's a pretty
dour panorama but
i do believe
that that we are being shown a lesson as
a country you're not done with this
subject
um i always think i am
but you know the thing is what i
realized during dreamland is that what
you're really you're i thought i was
writing about drugs and drug trafficking
and drug addiction no i really believe
it's
you have an opportunity through this
topic to write about america
we talked to sam and some of these
solutions are also pretty low tech it's
just getting outside and especially
during the pandemic so many people are
isolated it's spending time in the
community with friends family members
knowing that you're not alone first off
really great story important subject
matter i just know there's so many
people out there who wish that this
approach had been available to the
millions of people who were addicted to
cocaine and heroin and crack and got
excess and got incarcerated in the 90s
you know this is this is an approach
that looks like
it can work yeah and and the attitudes
are changing as we mentioned the piece
it used to be just like put them in
prison right forget about it clearly did
not work this is how you make change
jeff as michelle said great story